[ __ ]
so
so the scarlet witch's introduction into
the marvel cinematic universe is very
exciting
not so much in the sense that she is
going to be in the avengers 2 age of
ultron especially when you consider
that with the 10 issue limited series of
the age of ultron storyline
she didn't really have a huge part that
storyline actually revolved around
wolverine the invisible woman and hank
pym
but it's exciting for us because the
scarlet witch was and remains to this
day
a fan favorite she's been in marvel
comics for quite some time
and has engaged in storylines that have
had long and far-reaching effects into
the marvel comics universe as a whole
so unlike most of the marvel characters
that we've come to know and love
the backstory of the scarlet witch is
actually very difficult to really
ascertain
unless you know where to look with
characters like captain america the
incredible hulk
their backstories are told over a series
of comics but they are told over a
series of comics that belong
specifically to them
with the scarlet witch we get her
backstory over a series of comics
but the backstory or the very least the
comics seem to be disjointed
and you don't really know exactly where
to go if all you're doing is
looking for the backstory in order to
really understand the past
in order to understand what it was that
led up to the scarlet witch
becoming a member of the avengers we
first have to go back to before she was
born
and we actually to do a discussion about
her parents so starting with classic
x-men issue number 12 which was released
in 1987
we learned that the biological parents
of the scarlet witch
were max eisenhart and magda eisenhardt
now we do know that these two met up at
some point during world war
ii in the auschwitz concentration camp
but we don't really know how it was that
they were able to form a relationship
due to the fact that the concentration
camp
was sexually segregated meaning that
these sexes were kept away from one
another
we do know that once russian forces were
able to liberate the camp
the two escaped to the carpathian
mountains where they married and
eventually had a child anya eisenhart
at some point along the line max
eisenhart and magda eisenhart
leave the carpathian mountains and set
up residents
in a fishing port of sorts in a russian
territory
at this point max eisenhart is looking
for a forger an individual that can
create new identities for them
or the very least for him so that his
wife can take his last name
and that no one will really know who
they previously were
the forger creates a new identity for
max eisenhart called
eric lyncher and of course we know that
eric lyncher moves on to eventually
become magneto in the marvel comics
around the time that they had first
arrived and i believe it may have
actually been the first
night a fire erupts in the end that they
were staying at
uh magneto arrives in time to save magda
but he's unable to save his daughter
anya due to the fact that the local
members of the town
and some of them are involved in revenge
others are police detaining him and
physically assaulting him
prevent his ability to rescue his
daughter in a fit of rage and after his
daughter burns to death
he kills almost everyone there the only
person that survives
this the both the fire and magneto's
rage
is his wife magna of course anya had
burned to death
magda after seeing the destruction that
he had caused fled
now we don't really know if she fled
because of the fact that he had
demonstrated powers that
had really never been seen by her before
or because he had used his powers in
such a way
that it would cause extreme death and
destruction but we do know that
that magna had left left magneto and at
this point this brings an end to the
back story
with classic x-men number 12. we pick up
with the avengers issues number 185 and
186 with the stories
the yesterday quest and the knights of
wonder gore respectively
now these were released in 1979 and
these tell us what happens
after magda left magneto we do know that
when magda arrived at wondergore
mountain after leaving magneto
she was very very far along in terms of
her pregnancy in fact
within a few weeks of arriving she would
actually give birth to quicksilver
and the scarlet witch but we do know
that at this point magneto is unaware of
the twins
so we don't know if even magda herself
was unaware of her pregnancy when she
left
or if she was aware but due to the
circumstances chosen not to tell magneto
what ends up happening is that magda
arrives at wundergord mountain and she
is aided with the birthing process
by bova the midwife and bova the midwife
is a
sentient and bipedal bovine a cow and
she is actually one of several
genetic experiments at the hands of a
being named the high evolutionary
and the high evolutionary is for all
intents and purposes the ruler of wonder
mountain
although we're not going to go too far
into him suffice it to say
that he plays a moderately important
role in the life of
the scarlet witch later on down the road
around the time
that magna is giving birth we also see
two other individuals appearing robert
frank who plays the character whizzer
who has a very
similar set of powers to quicksilver
although he's not able to run as fast
and madeleine joyce frank who is miss
america
and of course her ability is to
manipulate um
her jumping process i think
using psionic means but suffice it to
say madeleine joyce frank is of course
pregnant
shortly after magda gives birth to
quicksilver and the scarlet witch
she leaves and she takes off her parts
unknown but we don't really know what
happens to her
it's presumed for the most part that she
dies of exposure but it's never been
concretely stated by marvel that this
was the case
suffice it to say madeleine joyce frank
miss america
dies during the birthing process and the
child is born
um stillborn it is in fact dead
and so mag i'm sorry bova takes quick
silver and the scarlet witch in attempts
to pass them off as the children of
madeleine joyce frank
to robert frank robert frank due to the
mental devastation of knowing that his
wife has died
rebukes the children and so bova takes
the children to a local village
where they are raised by the maximoffs
hence the reason why the scarlet witch
is named wanda maximov
and why quicksilver is named pietro
maximoff picking up with mystic arcana
issue number three
we learned that an occult had foretold
the coming of the scarlet witch
as a representation of quite possibly
the most powerful earthbound witch
to have ever existed at this time the
scarlet witch is around
11 years old maybe and she is inducted
or
is at least attempted to be inducted by
this occult into their ranks in order to
provide her with the training necessary
for her to fulfill her goal in the
process of demonstrating their power
the service or i guess the event is
interrupted by a being named cathone
and cathone had sensed the abilities of
the scarlet witch and intended to use
her as a means
to reconstitute himself in the physical
world of course his goal ultimately
fails
but in the process he does endow her
with a fraction of his power
shortly after this an event takes place
where the scarlet witch's powers begin
to manifest themselves
and an incident occurs whereby her roma
mother her adoptive mother
is accidentally killed and she is ran
out of town along with her brother
quicksilver in the
origin stories of the scarlet witch and
quicksilver avenger origins
we learned that there eventually comes a
point whereby they are traveling
together shortly after being uh
forced out of their local their adoptive
town and they come across
again another village whereby a man
attempts to
sexually assault the scarlet witch her
powers kind of go ballistic and manifest
and she sets
fire to a portion of the town the
superstitious crowd runs her out
but at the same time magneto appears and
magneto claims that both the scarlet
witch and quicksilver
are under his protection now at this
point magneto does not know that they
are his children however once they are
taken to his residence
some clues kind of begin to add up and
at the very least quicksilver comes to
the belief that the potential exists
that magneto may be his father however
at this point in time magneto really
kind of presents himself as a messiah or
as a leader
who will restore people of their kind to
the rightful order
and give them the kind of respect that
they have long deserved and to eliminate
the kind of oppression
that drove the scarlet witch and
quicksilver from their adoptive home
as well as the village in which magneto
had initially encountered them
as time progresses they initially joined
the ranks of the brotherhood of evil
mutants
and chronologically in the marvel comics
this is actually the first time that we
see quicksilver and the scarlet witch
they appear in x-men issue number four
in 1964 i think
and as a member of the brotherhood of
evil mutants they come into
conflict with both the x-men and the
avengers
but eventually as time progresses they
learned that magneto himself
is in fact the bad guy here and
eventually they turn against magneto
after
more or less kind of making the
statement that by virtue of magneto
having saved them
they have since paid their debt so to
speak they eventually joined the ranks
of the avengers
and this is where we see the scarlet
witch really kind of bounce around and
fluctuate a bit we see her fall in love
with a being named the vision
who was actually an android that was
created by ultron for the purpose of
destroying the avengers
shortly after this we begin to see signs
of the scarlet witch's mental
instability
and we begin to see her becoming
unhinged mentally that is to say
she becomes mentally insane and it is at
this point that she begins to present
herself
as a threat to not only the planet earth
inhumans and marvel characters alike
but also to a threat as a threat to the
marvel universe as a whole
so the abilities of the scarlet witch
can be very confusing if you're not an
avid reader of marvel comics
the very base abilities of the scarlet
witch that is to say her abilities
before she encountered the elder god
cathone
was the ability to manipulate energy to
create a wide array of effects energy
manipulation force field so on and so
forth
but once she interacts and once she
comes into contact and is bestowed
with a fraction of the power of the
elder god cathone
she is now able to manipulate what's
called chaos magic
and chaos magic is an extremely old
obscure
and very very powerful and dangerous
form of magic in the marvel comics it is
in fact
the most powerful form of magic and even
doctor strange the sorcerer supreme
the absolute authority for the most part
with regards to magics and sorcery and
marvel comics
was unaware that it actually existed
as the scarlet witch's powers begin to
develop as they begin to grow and as
this chaos magic
begins to manifest itself within her she
begins to use it to produce what's
called probability
manipulation now initially she doesn't
do this on purpose it just happens if
she is in a state of high duress
her hexes will appear and different
things will take place but as she gains
more control over probability
manipulation she finds herself being one
of the most important characters
with regards to the avengers simply
because she's able to manipulate the
probability
that a particular circumstance will work
out in their favor
now how it works out in their favor
varies depending on the circumstances
sometimes
ultron might short circuit or sometimes
an enemy might happen to look away at
just the right time
that it affords another member of the
avengers a chance to
you know to deal a critical strike but
eventually she comes into contact with a
true witch named agatha harkness
and when i say agatha harkness is a true
witch i mean that in the very sense of
the word
agatha harkness is not a mutant and
she's not an inhuman
she is in fact a true witch and she has
an expansive amount of knowledge with
regards to
magic and she tutors the scarlet witch
in the ability to manipulate her chaos
magic
as a scholar which becomes more
pronounced in her ability to manipulate
chaos magic
due to the tutelage of agatha hardness
she's able to in turn create force
fields
she's able to bring people back from the
dead she's able to
protect the lives of other people by
manipulating the very fabric of the
reality around them
and once she deals with dr strange we
see that her powers expand
even further but then we begin to come
across the point in the marvel comics
where again
her mental state begins to deteriorate
and this is where the scarlet witch
begins to present herself
as an extremely dangerous person because
not only is she effectively going insane
she is a person who's going insane that
also has the ability to alter reality
and it presents itself in such a way
that she is for the most part the most
detrimental person
in the marvel comics universe simply
because the result of her ability to
manipulate reality and any manipulations
of reality that she may create
may be due to a mental state that she
simply cannot reverse it
and it may be stuck that way forever and
this is when we see
charles xavier call together the x-men
the avengers and
a few other members of marvel comics to
determine the fate of wanda maximoff
and this is ultimately when we see the
house of m storyline rise
and then we see the house of him
storyline fall and the decimation
storyline
so what does it mean that we are going
to be seeing the scarlet witch in the
marvel cinematic universe
this is the question that everybody's
asking this is what everybody's
wondering
are we going to see anything more from
the scarlet witch are we going to see
her
in future films is marvel simply going
to keep her around as someone that's
part of the avengers team
but will never have her own solo film we
know that the scarlet witch and
quicksilver will have no tie-ins
whatsoever
to the inhumans so we don't know exactly
what the backstory is going to be
are they the result of genetic
manipulation is their backstory going to
be left obscure
until marvel can regain the rights to uh
the the term mutant
from fox do we know how all this is
going to work we don't really know we
have no idea what direction this is
going to be going in
but what we do know is that one of the
most beloved characters in marvel comics
is getting a chance to appear on the
silver screen even if it's only going to
be for one movie and even if during the
age of ultron storyline she appears
in some kind of passing scenario or
happens to join the avengers
off the cuff and then dies in the same
film at the very
least we will get a chance to see one of
our favorite characters on the silver
screen
and hopefully portrayed in a way that
does the character justice
with that being said i'm going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end i
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know
and i will catch you guys later peace